Don't worry, we're not teaching
you with a 1950s TV series.
This is actually a 2020
production. WandaVision is as
original of a TV show as anything I've ever seen.
This show is set in the Marvel cinematic universe
after the events of Avengers End Game and, if
you haven't watched it, I guarantee that after
watching this lesson you're going to be intrigued
as to what this unique show is all about.
But in case you're new here every week
we make lessons just like this one
to help you learn English without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles.
Just like Ahmed, who says that the three
days of the week that we publish lessons
are his favorite days of the week.
So make sure you hit that Subscribe
button along with the Bell down below so
you don't miss any of our new lessons.
So now keep watching to learn new
vocabulary and pronunciation with
WandaVision.
Now having a teacher's guidance can make a huge
impact on your learning, like how in this lesson
I'm teaching you vocabulary and pronunciation
from the scene to help you understand it, without
this guidance you might end up using vocabulary
and expressions that are not so common, sound
unnatural or you might even use them incorrectly.
But what if in just a few months you could
learn to speak confidently and fluently using
correct vocabulary, pronunciation and grammar.
Well with our friends over at Lingoda you
can become a Sprint Champion and get 100%
cashback, as well as access to the
renowned online Cambridge speaking test.
More than 40,000 learners all around the
world just like you have taken part in
Lingoda Sprint Challenges over the last three
years. And you can hear some of their inspiring
stories of success over on Lingoda's Instagram.
As a language learner myself I can tell you that
it's absolutely crucial that you have the guidance
and feedback from a qualified native teacher.
And one of the best things about Lingoda is
that it's flexible. Classes are available 24/7,
plus there are never more than five people
in a class, so you'll get to speak a lot.
Sounds great, right? Well let me give you some
more details about the Sprint: it starts on the
28th of April, 2021. Now you can participate in
the Super Sprint, where you can take 30 classes
a month for three months, and if you don't miss
a class you'll get 100% of your money back.
Or you can take part in the
Sprint, which is less classes
and you'll get 50% back. You can take English
or Business English as well as several other
languages and it's open to learners of all levels.
So what are you waiting for? Spots are limited and
you have to secure your spot before the 16th of
April. You have to pay a 49 Euro deposit to secure
your spot, but this will be put towards your
first month of classes, and as long as you attend
the agreed number of classes Lingoda will fully
refund your tuition, including your deposit fee.
Now remember to use our code to get 10 euros off
your deposit fee and you'll find that link and all
the information in the description box below.
Be sure to read the contest rules carefully
because students tell me that
this is the key to success.
I'd like to wish every one of you that
participates in the Lingoda Sprint good luck!
Now it's time to continue
learning with WandaVision.
If you'd like to learn some tips and
tricks on how to understand fast speech
I highly recommend you check out this lesson
we made over on our RealLife English channel.
You can click up here or down in the
description box below to watch it next!
If you're enjoying this lesson
then I highly recommend you check
out this lesson we made with Avengers End Game.
You can click up here or down in the
description box below to watch it next.
I hope you enjoyed today's lesson and also want
to remind you to check out that special Sprint
Challenge from our friends over at Lingoda.
They've been running their Sprint Challenges
for over three years now, and you can visit their
Instagram page for more inspiring success stories.
You can also learn more by clicking
the link down in the description box
below and remember if you sign up use our
code for 10 Euros off your deposit fee.
Good luck to everyone that participates!